it is september 2nd 2022 and you're
watching the code report well it was fun
while it lasted but my github co-pilot
free trial expired today and i'm way too
cheap to pay 10 a month for something
that will save me thousands of dollars
in hard manual labor and surprisingly
over ninety percent of developers out
there are just as good as me or are they
i've had access to it from the very
beginning and in some ways it's
incredibly helpful especially when it
comes to writing common boilerplate code
or when doing unit testing it
understands the context of the code
you've already written or that it wrote
for you and can bang out a bunch of
worthless unit tests to give you 100
code coverage to make your boss happy
that's pretty awesome but there are some
definite trade-offs here for one it's
almost too good and i feel like it makes
me more stupider like instead of using
my normal problem solving technique of
copying the top answer from stack
overflow i just trust that copilot knows
what it's doing but in a lot of cases
the code is actually not as good as it
looks at first your javascript throws a
segfault then you end up going back to
reverse engineer the copilot code when
really you could have done this all by
yourself but you just got lazy and ended
up wasting time the other problem i have
with copilot is that it sometimes just
makes annoying suggestions yes you can
toggle it on and off but that's also
annoying the biggest issue though is
that every time you use copilot it
collects a little more data and gets a
little bit better at what it does ai
just won its first art contest yesterday
at the colorado state fair and pissed
off a bunch of humans before you know it
ai is going to start winning every
hackathon it might still take another
year or two before it replaces us
completely but right now it feels a lot
like we're paying microsoft for the
privilege of digging our own graves i
think the only way to fight back is to
write terrible nonsensical spaghetti
code to ensure the co-pilot doesn't take
over as captain of this flight now if my
co-pilot trial expiring weren't bad
enough heroku also just recently
announced that they're getting rid of
their free tier it used to be one of the
easiest places to get a server postgres
database and redis cache in a single
location all for free but starting on
november 28 2022 all those free services
are going away now if you don't use
heroku you may not think that's a big
deal but this could be the first domino
to fall motivating other platforms to
also get rid of their free tiers as a
cheap ass developer with hundreds of
unfinished side projects i truly hope
that's not the case but in this current
economy tech stocks are in free fall
heroku is owned by salesforce which is
declined 50 from its peak earlier this
year free tiers are only there to drive
growth and if the user base isn't
growing then free tiers serve no other
purpose than to lose money they claim
it's to manage fraud and abuse and that
may be true to some extent but in my
opinion this looks a lot more like a
financial decision luckily there are
many other platforms that still have a
free tier you can get a free relational
database from planetscale free hosting
and edge functions from vercell or
cloudflare or all kinds of free stuff
from firebase and i'd be very surprised
if they ever eliminated their free tier
in fact i'm so confident that i'll make
the john mcafee promise right now to eat
my own pick on national television if
firebase ever gets rid of its free tear
i'd rather be suicided in a spanish
prison than see that happen but it's not
all bad news this week we did get a
brand new javascript framework this
one's called enhance and it has a
weirdly awesome logo but actually
provides a really awesome developer
experience when it comes to working with
web components what's interesting is
that it's using patterns very similar to
what i'm using to build the next version
of the fireship pro website it's very
cool to see another project thinking
about native web components in the
context of a multi-page application this
just in we have some breaking news i
encountered a regex problem then exactly
12 seconds later i went out and
purchased github co-pilot
this has been the code report thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one